au japon toutes les constructions
répondent aux normes antisismiques mais
ce soir une centrale nucléaire sur
laquelle a été d'essayer une fissure
reste sous surveillance et explications
avec federico nicotra le japon compte
pas moins de 16 centrales nucléaires en
fonctionnement sur son territoire au
moment du séisme
selon les informations disponibles les
automatismes d'arrêt aurait fonctionné
la seule chose que l'on sache c'est que
ces installations ont fonctionné
correctement dans le sens où elles se
sont mises à l'arrêt un état sûr suite
aux secousses sismiques et qu' il n'y a
pas de fuite radioactive qui est été
détecté ou rapporté à ce jour par les
autorités à l'institut de
radioprotection et de sûreté nucléaire
de fontenay-aux-roses l'évolution de la
situation est observé analysé à chaque
instant un incendie dans la centrale
d'onagawa serait maîtrisée mais ce qui
inquiète c'est le réacteur de la
centrale nucléaire de daiichi dans cette
centrale
un des réacteurs à des difficultés à
être refroidis
alors justement cette information est-ce
que vous elle vous inquiète
c'est assez préoccupant par ailleurs des
bons les nouvelles
évolué par ailleurs il apparaîtrait que
l'exploitant a réussi à mettre en route
un groupe électrogène mobile pour
justement apporter cette électricité
pour faire fonctionner le système de
refroidissement mais une autre
information moins rassurante vient
compléter ce propos selon la secrétaire
d'état américaine hillary clinton
l'air force vient de transporter un
produit de refroidissement très
important vers l'une des centrales
nucléaires du japon